- Being here two years in a row now,
I feel like I've become
somewhat of an expert
at everything comic book related.
(audience laughing)
Don't laugh at that.
I was being serious.
(audience laughing)
- Really, an expert?
- Yeah, no, absolutely.
When it comes to comic
books, superhero movies,
sci-fi, fantasy, all things Comic-Con,
there is literally no bigger expert
than this big hunk sittin' right here,
I'm telling you right now.
I really believe that.
- All right, well--
- [Conan] I believe that!
- Well, then you should have no problem
passing the just invented
Comic-Con Citizenship Test,
administered by the director
of a little independent film
called Star Wars the Force Awakens,
JJ Abrams!
(audience cheering)
(imperial marching music)
- Wow!
- Thank you.
Wow!
That is amazing!
(cheering)
- That's--
- Unbelievable!
- [Conan] It's pretty nice!
- This is crazy.
- Pretty nice. I can't
believe you're doing this.
You're going to administer, this is crazy!
- Oh please, you know, you
might know a few things
about comic books and movies,
but your training's not yet complete.
(audience laughing)
Are you ready?
- JJ, let's do this.
I think I'm ready for this,
and I think I'm gonna do a great job.
(audience cheering)
- All right, here we go.
What class, thanks.
- [Andy] Mm-hmm.
- What class of star ship
is the Millennium Falcon?
- Oh come on, that's easy.
A Corellian YT-1300 light freighter.
(dinging)
- Yes.
(audience cheering)
In the Lord of the Rings trilogy,
what city is the capital of Gondor?
- Minas Tirith.
Come on.
(dinging)
- Who is the star of both
Guardians of the Galazy
and Jurassic World?
- CGI.
- [JJ] Yes.
(audience laughing)
- What is Vin Diesel's real name?
- Truck Lasertank.
(dinging)
(audience laughing)
- What two movies
preceded Star Trek Beyond?
- Star Trek Bed and Star Trek Bath.
- Yes.
(dinging)
(audience laughing)
Complete this sentence, "Batman and--"
- Robin.
(dinging)
- Spider-Man and--
- Mary Jane.
(dinging)
- Ant-Man and--
- Anyone willing to hang out with Ant-Man.
(dinging)
- Yes.
(audience laughing)
Which 2015 sci-fi film
warned us what could happen
if beautiful robots gained too much power?
- The Entourage movie.
(dinging)
(audience laughing)
- If there's something weird
and it don't look good,
who you gonna call?
- My dermatologist.
(dinging)
(audience laughing)
- Name the big, angry comic book character
who looks like he's made of orange rocks.
- Donald Trump.
(dinging)
- Yes.
(audience cheering)
What happens to the male
sex drive as one ages?
- The force a'weakens.
(dinging)
(audience laughing)
- Deadpool is--
- A mercenary with
superhuman healing factor.
(dinging)
- Deadpool is also--
- The swimming venue at the Rio Olympics.
(dinging)
- Yes.
(audience laughing)
(audience groaning)
(Andy laughing)
- [Andy] We got a pro-Zika crowd here.
- What do you call Joss
Whedon doing yard work?
- Joss Whedon weedin'.
(dinging)
(audience laughing)
- What are Spock's famous last words
in Star Trek II: The Wrath of Khan?
- See you on the
flippity, my funky friend.
(dinging)
(audience laughing)
- How do you kill a troll?
- Take away his internet access.
(dinging)
(audience laughing)
(audience cheering)
- Name three fictional doctors.
- Doctor Doom, Doctor
Octopus, and Doctor Phil.
(dinging)
(audience laughing)
- In the Harry Potter novels,
what is the recipe for Polyjuice Potion?
- Okay, recipe for Polyjuice Potion.
Step one, add three measures
of fluxweed to the cauldron.
Step two, add two bundles of knotgrass
then stir three times
clockwise, wave your hand.
Let it brew for 80 minutes,
then add four leaches, then
two scoops of lacewing flies
that have been crushed into
a fine powder, if you will.
Simmer for 30 seconds on low
heat, wave your hand again.
Then three measures of Boomslang skin,
one measure of crushed bicorn horn,
heat for 20 more minutes.
Wave your hand a second time,
let it brew for 24 hours,
then add another scoop of lacewing.
Stir three times anti-clockwise,
then add the piece of the
person you wish to become
and wave your hand one last time.
Boom, Polyjuice potion.
(dinging)
(audience cheering)
- Uh, and finally,
my stopping by to
administer this test was--
- A complete waste of your time.
- Yes.
(dinging)
(laughing)
(audience cheering)
- Let's hear it for JJ Abrams, everybody!
That was great.